yeah and we are live good afternoon good
evening good morning
Hallelujah wherever the hell you are in
the world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel let's go to
the screens and say hello to everybody
Matthew how you doing hello I'm doing
good how are you doing
I'm doing good baby
young Aaron is with us
young Aaron I'm older than everyone here
are you older than me hello yeah
remember we established that I'm 47
you're 45 I even have two years on you
two years oh my God damn it but I'm so
much prettier and
the young young boy yeah there we go
hey Addie how are we doing
um I actually watched a really good
sci-fi movie yesterday
um but I did get a few comments because
I mentioned it on a video
um and it's 100 sci-fi High concept
science fiction
um I watched the festival series 10
movies
um I I get the I pay the subscription so
I go to the cinema and I I don't I can
go to cinema as many times as I like so
I I always I always think that sort of
film you're gonna go what you think as
long as you turn your brain completely
off and you don't you completely ignore
gravity physics how Metal Works and fire
in this one how fireworks and all of
that stuff it's entertaining I was
laughing my ass off at all the bits they
weren't they weren't supposed to it's
good I enjoyed it it's a good film and
you know the best part of it all
um Ronan freaking dicks oh yeah
he looks like does such a great job in
the trailers
he has a laugh with it didn't he he has
a good laugh with it and he just you can
tell how funny he had how much fun he
had doing it it was I had I thought it
was a good movie it was a lot better
than F9
oh God yeah well nobody ended up in
space or ran over a satellite in space
that was that that went way too far
that's something that actually happened
yeah did you not see it it was duct tape
I've never watched Fast and Furious
the reason being when they first come
out it was all about cars on that I'm
not really into cars but I didn't really
but now I've seen like where they've
gone with it I kind of want to see it
but I thought it's
ridiculously laughing out loud and I'm
there going I'm not supposed to be
laughing at this so this is
laughing my ass I've seen the first step
that's a benefit that's definitely a
benefit oh she's lovely so anyway today
about a little bit of Stargate news I've
got some good news and a little bit of
bad news
um the people have spoken in the
comments before the live stream started
and we're going to be starting with the
bad news and then I'll hit you with a
little bit of good news that's actually
only a rumor and does lead back into the
bad news so we'll we'll talk about that
in one second but first of all we um
[Music]
foreign
as well actually run the damn thing and
then
we'll go straight into the news
[Music]
so the bad news first there is are
several discussions at the moment going
on at MGM and Amazon about when they
should announce the
um New Stargate franchise my sources are
telling me at the moment that it is
still looking like it's going to be the
movie that's the way they're pushing
it's going to be a cinematic release
that's the way they're pushing and the
plan is right now that this will get
announced at San Diego Comic-Con I say
right now because I don't know if
everyone's noticed but there is a right
to strike going on
so there's been some discussion
um literally last week about whether it
was appropriate to announce this during
the register strike or would it
come across as a little bit of bad taste
then the Actors Guild of America is it
sag for Harris is that right
after well sorry after uh actors yeah
yeah
it really wasn't listening
um yes
but now the actors have basically put
down and it looks like they might
actually strike as well
so that leads back into the good news
which I'll tell you in a second
um or causes a problem for the good news
which I'll tell you in a second so there
are two camps at the moment there's one
side of the
um PR people who are saying screw it
let's just announce it
um it's a bit of good news doing a load
of negativity so let's let's throw it
out there let's talk about RoboCop let's
talk about Stargate let's talk about
um Legally Blond three which we're all
going to be obviously doing many many
videos about
um and then but there's another camp
that is saying basically look this is
going to make this good backfire on us
this could make us look really really
like we don't give a crap about what's
going we need to do we need social best
solidarity what's going on this could
actually backfire really badly and
become a bad news story for us instead
of
the positive story that we're going on
as it stands right now
there's no decision
now a very good friend of the channel
um has actually confirmed me that this
this is basically what's going on that
person I won't
say the name but
um you know was heavily involved in MGM
we won't refer than that they were
saying that exactly the same story that
there's these two camps and but there's
been a lot of division within MGM and
Amazon anyway we know this because
there's the camp want to make the movie
there's a camp that want to make the
series there's a camp that they still
want to do a reboot but they're quite
you know being laughed at basically in
pointer
um so let's see what happens
um in in over the next couple of weeks
San Diego Comic-Con might actually have
an awful lot of things being pulled out
of like the Warner Brothers had booked
several big rooms so semi Comic-Con and
apparently they're canceling them
because they don't want to announce
things so even they're pulling out and
they're going to have a lot more
interactive stuff instead at the
Comic-Con instead of
about the big announcements and the big
you know getting all the actors on stage
and things the big problem they've said
is the if the actors go on strike
they can't do the good news which is
that Amanda Tapping and Richard Dean
Anderson have apparently been booked for
San Diego Comic-Con
so if this is obviously what we were
looking for that if we thought we were
going to get the announcement
that we wanted a couple of the big
original actors to be actually booked to
be there because then they would be part
of the announcement amount of that thing
and Richard Dean Anderson as of now are
supposed to be at San Diego Comic-Con
unless they're on strike in which case
they won't be
so that is the news
we'll be straight back in one second and
we will discuss it nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at ninechevrons.com
I tried to do an advert of my own for
one of those by the way and it was so
bad I put it on um patreon just for
people to say the piss out of me
awful and they did they really took a
piss on me I I hate that advert I I
think that is awful well there's some
people playing it and I just hit him up
now I'm sure everyone's got shut up
[Laughter]
but guys what do we think what's what's
the initial right first of all Richard
Dean Anderson and Amanda Tapping being
booked here at San Diego Comic Con too
can we read between the lines in there
and think that that might be something
to do with the announcement or actually
they're doing a lot of comics
putting those two in a room putting
those two in a room if they were this if
if it was just one or the other you
could think yeah maybe they're just
there as likes fan service for
um you know the people that want to go
to see like if it was originally
answering for example to talk about
MacGyver to talk about Stargate how he's
done in the past and if it was Amanda
Tapping to talk about like Travelers and
all the stuff that she's done in the
past but them two in the same room at
the same time it has to be Stargate
because I can't think of anything else
top of my head there might be something
but I can't think of it that those two
have been in
that people at Comic-Con would be
interested in again though they have
been appearing in Comic Cons all over
Europe they're about to appear at
Hamburg they're another one a couple of
months ago they've been doing a lot of
Comic Cons which is all again I'm being
told part of the the fact that they're
doing it together which they think I
mean Richard Dean Anderson didn't do
comic cons for ages but then last two
years or so we started again and
apparently this is all part of the plan
to get Stargate in the public eye as
much as possible yeah
ready for the announcement how about you
Anna what do you think
well first of all
okay
um uh yeah wait for a second and I only
caught the end of that that's that
scared me to death oh sorry it's just
you know the holy [__] violence again
oh God no Nicholas please no
um
but yeah no it's I'm with you I don't
see any way it has nothing to do with uh
the show coming back in whatever form
they're going to do it in
um hopefully a series that's just me but
uh like the only thing I can think of is
like I wish they had one more cast
member of the crew up there with them
because like if you think about it the
other two big star fill in the blank
franchises they both have their trios
you know you got a Han Luke and Leia for
Star Wars you got Kirk Spock and McCoy
for Star Trek
it'd be dope if they had either Shanks
or uh judge with them so you could have
O'Neill Carter and you know either
Jackson or teal you know just I'm a
Libra I like the balance so I just think
it'd be a little more dope if they had a
third one
overall yeah
I think there'll be more names I think
those are the two that are booked in
um
I wouldn't be surprised if he did also
tag along
yeah
so how about you Harris what do you
think
oh I mean I'm ecstatic I I'd love for
them to actually do it I kind of expect
sag to strike so I don't know if we will
be able to see them
but if sag doesn't strike it would be
great I mean that this is kind of what
we need at kind of an event that size it
has been cool to see them go into all
these different Comic Cons and stuff but
San Diego Comic Con is a whole different
animal and that's the perfect place to
announce things if something were to be
announced
please
in with the strikes going on
we're all still fans of things and we
all still want good news I I I don't
think good news is gonna hurt as long as
it's good news and it's not like a
double-edged sword whenever they
announce something then I think if it
was a double-edged sword and then it
might be a little uh I'd be hesitant to
announce but if it's just straight up
good news something that all the fans
and like new people would like alike or
like as well
announce it you know yeah there's
nothing good going on might as well I
think announcing it is probably the best
thing they can do because they know that
we know there's a right strike on and we
know that nothing but a lot of things
aren't going to get announced a lot of
things aren't going to be made for a
while because of this we've we've seen
it happen in 2008 a lot of things got
canceled a lot of things didn't get made
we know what's going to happen we know
what we know what to expect so
with with all that in mind
fortune favors to bold just announce it
and have a little bit of good news as
Harry said
I I should say that um I'd say gone
fishing has just said and that is right
in Amanda Staffing is supposed to be
there for motherland as well but the
point is that Amanda Tapping and Richard
Dean Anderson have been booked in to
appear together which is obviously going
to be separate to anything else
um as amberlynn mentioned that
um Christopher Judge might be there
because of goddess of war like but again
if he was to appear it would be separate
so um but yeah I
strike happened as well
that then it wouldn't happen but um I
don't think the wide writers can strike
by then mechanics isn't the negotiations
not even start till June 1st
and it's my understanding the they're
they're just preparing for the
conversation I think there's then a
month so but even if they did strike
would that prevent actors from appearing
at something like this I think if it was
planned industrial action they probably
wouldn't be able to do it but if it's
not planned then they would yeah if it's
if it's like Studio kind of thing if
it's not them and their agents making
the plans I guess and it is like through
the studio I think then it may be more
official which would cancel them out
from being able to do it
it was somebody that works in an agent
side of things that's told me this okay
but
um everything's saying
they said that they wouldn't I don't
think he meant that they necessarily
couldn't
um but I think it was more that if if
that's the way it's looking he believes
the actors would rather not and I can
understand that because they don't want
to cause maybe a bit of controversy they
want to show some solidarity to the
cause or whatever and doesn't undermine
the the reasoning for
the the strike action if they're then
doing things like this maybe
I mean that makes sense too I I can see
that being the reasoning as well if
they're not like beholden to not doing
it uh
still come on we could use some joy we
could use some Joy
I think we're sorry because they're
actually trying to
do this with it with the you know that
you know they're striking for a reason
aren't they if they then then stand up
on stage and announce a new TV show I
think maybe
does it take the wind out of the sales
of the action a little bit
so I mean it's like it is like I can see
I can see it from that point of view
um but
the people who kind of us as fat I'm not
going to say us
here because like fully support the
right right strike whatever they they
need to strike because they need Fair
conditions to work and pay Etc but the
bottom line that most fans are gonna
want is that something is in production
or something has been planned and that's
what we that's what they're going to
care about
I think everyone is in so everyone
uh supports the writers no one is
um
uh thinking ill of the writers for going
on strike and you know delaying all
these projects Etc because it's it's
industrial action happens all over the
world and it's something that is it's
important it's an important thing that
needs to happen yeah
um
but yeah I think
as if if we know something's coming as
fast if we know something is wrong we
got something to get excited about
so we can we can we can support the
writers as they're as they're doing
their industrial action like go go get
your go get the bag you know go go get
what you deserve
and when you're ready
go make the thing that we're excited
about
yeah I I I'd hope most people think like
that but well I mean I don't know Aaron
I'll ask you what you think of this
thing so is there a point in announcing
Stargate development when the writers
are on strike because really it's just
is it an empty gesture because you can't
actually do anything
uh for me yeah if there's strikes going
on announcing an upcoming project
without being able to say we have this
project coming
and you can't even give a window right
now like it's just okay we're planning
this
and you'll see it
sometime
I mean that's the best they can do with
any kind of announcement right now
um especially if sag after goes on
strike which
the board authorized
the grain can file the vote and I think
the rank and file overwhelmingly voted
to strike if I'm not mistaken
for sure so I'm not sure about the vote
yeah I just sent it all out yeah so I
think the people out there I don't see
any I don't see anything after it
doesn't join the train I'm I feel like
yeah they're striking I feel like um at
this point in time the unions are going
to probably show a lot more solidarity
than they have in the recent past for
this one so I think we all need to like
buckle up in like lower our expectations
and when we're going to see certain
projects by quite a bit
right now well those are the two things
the only way I could say this is is my
understanding is for the movie
there's already a script
so that's one option one possibility but
then Harris if you can't get actors up
on the stage to announce this what's the
point of doing it in San Diego Comic-Con
I mean yeah
it kind of really begs the question is
is it's kind of just a nothing burger at
that point if we do have to wait
an indefinite amount of time just just
to have anything uh just to begin
because then once production starts it's
another three four five months
production and then reshoots and
whatever they need to do uh whether it's
a film or or a show and then
post-production is going to be another
three four five six months that's
another year year and a half that we're
gonna have to wait in marketing and
everything else that's included
it may be best best just to hold off
until later this year or whenever they
could announce as sad as it could be of
course I'm a little Optimist and like
come on announce it give us something uh
happy to talk about but
realistically that might not be the best
case scenario uh for them for the studio
to announce if they can't do anything
about it
yeah to play Devil's Advocate if they
were to announce it
could they not announce
just not not an official announcement
yes it's coming how about
we're working on something we have been
planning for
12 months let's say because it's
probably been about that about that long
where they've been actually seriously
considering this we've been working on
things we have a script we have actors
who are potentially signed on for this
but for now we are we stand in full
solidarity with the industrial election
that's going on with the riot strike the
rights Guild of America and
I I don't I I'm not going to say
the other one because I can't remember
what it was and I don't want to butcher
it
um
so it kind of negates the the backlash
that could come from
is this bad taste because they're just
saying that we've got something in them
in the in the works and once
everyone is happy we're going to push
forward with it yeah that could be an
option Michelle's made a point here
about
um movies need rewrites and TV series
they need to rewrite during
um development
it's not as true anymore as it used to
be
um now because of like particularly a
movie like this is going to have such
heavy special effects the movie does
need to be very heavily planned before
and then things do happen yeah the
script something works or doesn't work
and you know they have to rework things
as they go along
but nowadays particularly with very
heavy special effects movies
that they don't tend to do as much
fiddling with the script as they go
along as they used to there used to be
there's a writer on the floor and
something around the director be like I
don't like this line and they'd rewrite
it because of the because the special
effects are being done alongside it's
not as easy to do that because if you
change something
quite small and on you know on the live
action all of a sudden that could ruin a
million dollars worth of uh special
effects that you've that are already set
up or already halfway through rendering
or whatever else so it's it's not as
it's not it's still true it's not as
true as it used to be with this sort of
film
so they really needed a pretty
decent robust script before they start
or at least it's all storyboarded out
Etc yeah the Virgin and things can
change along the line but that tends to
change anyway because the director
doesn't need a writer to go
do I want you to do something a bit
different with this line do you know the
thing and that but then you don't
necessarily need to write a sat there to
do that
um even though writers Apparently after
while songwriters hate it when I have to
do that
um well if what we we've heard was true
they probably do already have a pretty
robust script if Amazon did hire
external writers and things like that to
LIT to literally because they knew this
was happening
to get the script
production ready
so it might be in a position where they
wouldn't need to do rewrites at all
because they would have already been
sent off approved
revised approved again revised again
approved again because it's been what
three
four months of of doing that constantly
it would have been probably yes well we
believe Mark Fergus has been involved in
this and again the close friend of the
channel confirmed me literally yesterday
again that they believe Market is still
very heavily involved in this we've been
questioning whether there's I've had no
more negotiations happening since
Christmas but they're saying no it is
I've got some exciting news about that
remind me to tell you when we finish
live because I can't say it on the
stream
um but um
so um
he could have he could have done a
script because we think he's been
involved for about nine months yeah
so
there may be a movie script there
and it could be it could have been
developed over months and we just don't
know because it would be within
um
I think
obviously this is just based on
everything we know so far that the
original script that he would have made
would have been a two-part pilot
that they adapted and that's why they
needed to hire those external writers
as like additional support to adapt that
into the movie because of um
what's her name Jennifer sulke wanting
the movie and pushing so hard for it now
that's happening they needed to adapt it
and that's why they did all of the
adaptations and they would have adapted
it and then revised it Etc I think
that's
probably what's happened
[Music]
obviously that I don't know that for a
fact don't take that as word but that is
just like reading between the lines of
everything that we heard for the past
six months yeah does anyone know
Amazon's filming style or
um
yeah
like for example they choke bags of
money at Studios
the only reason I ask is because like
you take Marvel for example they
constantly rewrite I mean flagy if he
doesn't like something well outside of
phase four
um flag if he doesn't like someone he
comes in there like the Hulk's like
um no no no this is what we're doing now
making a movie and like
Multiverse of Madness they basically
re-shot that movie like in the three
months before it was released like
completely redid just about everything
and you can really tell please
it's a drunk mess and the special
effects are in places like that the
Matrix the second Matrix and they have
the plasticine
um fights battle when it looks like yeah
I've seen men fighting each other the
special effects in Multiverse amount is
in places
were worse than that and that's a film
that was 20 years ago in places it's
it's it's properly like
early
you know like when they started putting
like the first Spider-Man with Toby
McGuire sort of thing it's it's it's not
good in places and the third eye just
look weird
um but now a bit of a bit of a drunk
mess up for me I tried to watch it again
I couldn't watch it so yeah I've watched
that thing like five or six times in
total but I'm a samurai I'm a Sam Raimi
sent like I love I love that yeah and so
like it like all the little bits of Evil
Dead that I saw in there I was just like
sitting in the theater like
those were the best kids
I thought it was an entertaining movie
um but
[Music]
yeah it was it wasn't great in terms of
like if you look at it critically it's
not a great movie but it was
entertaining and I think that's what
they had going through and the cameos
were great as well so yeah well that's
true in the comments we've been talking
about this fed con so who who Harris you
had a quick look who else is there oh
you're gonna pull it up real quick
there's a huge lineup it's it's the trio
that we just asked for it's Richard Dean
Anders Anderson Amanda Tapping Michael
Shanks there's Ben Browder Joe
Flanagan's there Elena Huffman Terrell
rothery Tony Amendola Anna Louise
Plowman and Patrick Curry oh and Simone
Bailey and John Delancey Connor trynter
oh Michael I just watched him in SGA uh
Marina Sirtis and that and that's it
that's a great great
lineup it is 90 Stargate
where the hell is fedcon
but I was going to ask where's fedcon
is at the maritime hotel in somewhere
and bond what does b-o-n-nn
it used to be West Germany when I was a
kid but yeah it's in Germany so there's
a big one in Germany I'm just wondering
yeah um and there's a Stargate
convention in base in Stoke literally
last week and
um
and we didn't know about it well it was
I don't think it was a Stargate
convention I think it was a Comic-Con
but um and Richard Johnson were there I
believe all right I could have took time
off work for that
all right I have not seen fast X but
House of treaties you speak heresy
this is the most part of fast X every
time he's on screen the movie got worse
I know he was the best beating it for me
he was the only part that was like he
wasn't truly serious he was having fun
with it everything else was serious but
like it was fun yeah but it was cringy
it felt like it was purposefully cringy
in so many parts like I don't I didn't
get that bit still a hell of a lot
better than F9 but
yeah that wasn't cringy
I was just ask you this though because
if you've got a big convention like that
in Germany and when you've got 90 of the
class there
and you don't think you can do San Diego
Comic-Con if you were the pr if you were
the people the pr people
um Stargate would you be like why don't
we just do it internally
why don't we just break it there
that's a sort of decision they could
make last minute they could do that like
two or three days before and go you know
what screw it let's just do it
would that would that be a way of
getting around
like writer strikes because it's in
America isn't it the strikes
under solidarity with them right now
from what I've seen
there is a lot of solidarity going on
but yeah I mean point they're striking
in America like EastEnders is still
running over in in Coronation Street and
everything and you know the active over
here is still working man
not not the writers all over the world
yeah so I mean that was one of the
things they said that actually
I I think the Canadian isn't the
Canadian writer's Guild but they are
quite close to um the American girl
don't they but one of the arguments I
could do as well
if they make this in Canada
the writer strike don't matter
just do it in Canada
they did they did make the entirety of
Stargate in Canada before
but
Toronto's only gotten bigger and better
and better bigger better and more badass
since then you know I think I think if
they did that that would be in bad taste
because that's literally the country
that's right next door you're basically
then saying
you guys were on strike here we're gonna
go next door to do it
yeah I think that is slightly in bad
taste
um
no no I mean I
think they should be more of a we we are
working on something and we stand in
solidarity with everyone at the moment
get what you need and then and then
we're gonna push on I think that's
probably the best way they can do it
where there's guilds in Europe that
won't touch anything that comes from
here regardless
I think one way of getting around it
though is they can argue it was always
filmed in Canada yeah so we're not doing
anything we're not doing anything dodgy
we're not moving a project to Canada
you'd argue with like this is a
Vancouver project it was it's just going
home
so you know it's fine and Mark Fergus we
brought him a house in Vancouver he's
happy he loves polar bears and that's
where he is so this is companies called
penguin and Parker he loves the cold
exactly
so what's the problem you know believe
it anyway
that's the penguin is wearing a Parker
that penguin does not like the cold
um that's a um one thing I did think
about when we when we were talking about
this and and if they did announce it
like things that could backfire
it's something that's already happened
in the past with Stargate where they
green light project and they announce it
to the world
What if after writers strike and after
the active skills strike and all things
like all this kind of stuff what if
something then happens which means they
can't push on and they have to cancel
the project what if we're going to get
another percent to what happened with
the trilogy of films from Dean Devlin
Roman limerick
I don't want that
this this all this stuff going on at the
moment
one way or another is going to be
resolved in the next
seven eight weeks something like that I
think the right the ACT is going on
strike and then all this is going to
force the studios to make a compromise
that works and this could all end very
quickly
when is Comic-Con it's like 15th of June
or something isn't it yeah it's mid-june
it goes on for like two weeks or it's
well over a week
um most Comic Cons like two maybe three
days in they certainly overcome in the
UK they are yeah I don't know I don't
know about the American ones
they're usually like Friday through
Sunday
well we're going next year I'm
determined the map if you've got to
speak to your wife
I I did speak to her and she hated the
idea to begin with
yeah no and then and then I I base it
basically will just like fine I won't go
I know she's like oh no you should go
okay
hotels and everything around me or on
the channel so um and flights and then
yeah road trip baby
so that is this next year hopefully
oh yeah and we're going to do videos
with um Harris cooking for us and come
on be brilliant we can be in a state
where things are legal
yes things are legal things that I'm not
gonna do so I'm just I'm just going to
start there doing videos
right here in Michigan drinking I'll be
I'm over 21. what are you talking about
I
laughs
right we anyway I'm gonna get into the
uh next bit of the video where we're
going to be talking about some of the
Stargate starships and we're gonna bit
of fun with that but first of all we'll
just run another trailer
Sidetrack also has some amazing merch
get yours today and show your support at
side-track.com
right so
um I really need to refilm it and kind
of just put a little bit more enthusiasm
into it because it's very much Hydra has
some amazing merge
I absolutely hate it
please
how did you go and visit our patreon
patreon.com all of that money will go
into our um plane tickets so that'd be
lovely
um before we move on to that though we
will talk about the petition very
quickly so we want Brad Wright to be
involved in some way with Excuse me the
new Stargate project
not necessarily show running I
personally want some fresh blood I want
some new ideas but
at the end of the day Brad Wright is
better with sorry if I write it's better
with Stargate probably with but Stargate
is better with Brad right than without
him so we've gone past 3 000 signatures
which is amazing in less than a week we
want to keep pushing that I know it's
slowed right down again now so we need
to be sharing this I need to share it
with some of the actors and things let's
even get one of them to jump on board on
Tech talk about two days ago and we got
like an extra 100 signatures on there
from that so fantastic so let's do that
again but guys we need you to help us
with this we need it to be shared
anywhere with anyone go on Twitter you
know put all the ACT if the actors get
something from me they might ignore it
but if they get bloody 50 requests to
look at the petition then one of them
might share it and that's what really
get some big numbers so get on there
there's a link Michael Shanks who's
really active on Twitter if you tweet
him he might respond because I've
tweeted him before and he's responded so
just Spam him Daniel Daniel share this
Daniel
my name's not Daniel but yes it is
Daniel Daniel digital
um but yeah let's do it so guys get on
there let's get it done because that's
how we make this and if we shout out
loud enough you never know maybe they'll
listen
um
someone make a shirt with a QR code to
the link and then send it to Michael
Shanks to wear it fedcon
yeah oh the right idea it's free to take
a QR code and make it off of Google
Chrome all you got to do is print that
puppy on a white T-shirt and send it
Matthew there you go mate you got a job
for Uncle next week so cracker I could
do that too
you've got we've got to do the T-shirt
as well oh no that's gonna take me a
week a week paying like for my time
about it's gonna take like three hours
[Laughter]
I'm not sure I agree with this
um thing of Harris is a genius but
that's that was a good idea so why not
um a Futurama genius
that still makes me angry I I like woke
up in the middle of the night a couple
weeks ago in Harris
best sci-fi so ever the idiots when
you're ready for the Revival one was it
what is it June June 24th is it yeah
it's coming back well they're Reviving I
didn't even know it ended
yeah it's ended about nine times but
anyway it's like South Park it keeps
coming back life finds a way yeah
Carrie's on it everyone clicked that
right he wants to do starts then we're
going to be doing a couple of our
favorite Starships from the Stargate
um franchise it was I'll tell you Matt
do you want to go first are you ready oh
yeah
do it so first of all what are you
talking about well the [__] that I want
to talk about because it is the greatest
show in my opinion in the entire
Stargate franchise it's not the most
powerful [__]
but at the time it was on the air it was
and it kicked ass it is anubis's
Mothership
it is so good it's I love the attack
vessels
pyramids they run by the grow old love
the grow world but this ship was souped
up to the max
it had ancient like Weaponry ancient
Shields and the scene let me see if I
can find the scene I think this is the
scene here
you knew something was going to kick off
here all of the grow old motherships
like they all joined in unity the only
time in in probably in history where the
guy will all in unison agreed
unanimously to take on one enemy
and they got their asses kicked it was
amazing I absolutely loved it
it was a hell of a ship it was like for
me that was
do you know when we're watching Stargate
and at different you have different
Peaks the bit where
Anubis took the ship and destroyed
abinos was that I mean the show I
already adored the show but that was
just like another pick that was just
like this is another level this is like
I mean this is this is like we've not
seen anything like this before this is
just astonishing
um I think it really highlighted how
how much of a threat Anubis was because
we knew he was half ascended and he had
knowledge of the Ancients but we didn't
really know how much knowledge he had
and then this ship came in and we were
like oh he has that much he has a quite
a bit of knowledge
like and we learned a bit about ra as
well didn't we because it was the ifrah
that allowed him to yeah the to create
the super weapons so again we sort of
found a little bit more about our rise
to power and then he took a nuclear
weapon to the face and um
I'm not entirely sure about this but
isn't the Eye of Ra and all the
associated gems something to do with the
Ancients anyway probably I'm pretty sure
like relics because everything to go I
all did was was stolen I don't think
they would have created it but yeah as
far as I know they were all part so so
his knowledge that they existed and what
they were actually for and he could
actually put them into prep into a
feasible like
practical use
like it probably wasn't designed let's
let's be honest by the Ancients it
wasn't designed to power a super like a
super spaceship and destroy an entire
flight it was probably like it was for
power but probably not for that
and I just loved Anubis has always been
my favorite
um villain in Stargate yeah
in star in sci-fi full stop yeah he was
one of my favorite villains he could
take the knowledge which is essentially
at its core probably
created by the ancients for something
quite pure and quite nice and he twists
it and he uses it for evil and it's just
amazing
I love it when villains do that they
take something pure which is like
designed for something not nefarious and
then they're just like nope
you twist it and now I'm gonna kill you
with it it's like the double switch it's
great I love it
so yeah the Anubis Mothership
in the show
the best ship in the show best ship in
the show the Euro it's way more powerful
so are some of the Asgard ships but that
is the best [__] because of how
frightening at the time it was how
powerful it was at the time
because he he literally leveled the
playing field and he stepped up he
stepped up his
his
um his position in the universe in the
Galaxy at that point
without that ship he wouldn't have been
able to ascend to the the power that he
had
sure
so anubis's Battleship I'm just gonna
just think of silly little
um comparisons so anubis's Mothership
versus
Shadow vessel from Babylon 5 who wins
don't even know
actually I don't think any of you guys
like a Pablo 5D
I started watching it I have started
watching it yeah
sometimes that's a really crap okay
screw that let's not bother anyway so
yeah
do it based on ships from Target
Universe from the Stargate not soccer
Universe from the Stargate Universe so
okay well how about against the destiny
I guess definitely it would it would
obliterate Destiny Destiny is not a
powerful ship it's a very nice it's not
a warship at all it's got decent Shields
but it's from a time when the ancients
it predates Atlantis so the technology
is going to be way it's going to be
essentially the way I would look at it
Bronze Age versus now
yeah
how about then against the next
vessel on the story but first of all
we'll let
um Aaron tell us why he loves the ship
he's picked and then who would win in a
fight between the two so uh
I went with the Asgardian vessel
um that's their most powerful ship they
ever created it was the flagship yes
observe the O'Neill compared to the
normal Asgardian battle cruiser or
whatever that you want to call it that's
the Basilisk version yeah there's the
O'Neill I mean it had it had their
fastest hyperdrive engine
it had their most powerful Weaponry it
was built to take on the replicators
that was why they built it so it had to
be just like insanely op
um
yeah I'd have 15 transporters
yeah This ship's just straight up sick
and it is
insanely powerful I mean it it's wiping
out attacks with one shot
um the shields are so good it could
actually take an Ori plasma weapon blast
and still exist which most ships
couldn't
um
so yeah
the O'Neill didn't last very long though
did it no no they they sacrif well they
sacrificed the O'Neill itself but they
made more of that class of ship
that's the one that they chucked into
hyperspace let the replicators follow it
and then blew it up
yep when the replicators or not the
replicators when the Asgard were too
smart to come up with a battle plan so
they recruited Sam because you know
smart for a human but way way less
intelligent than at the time so they're
like we wouldn't think if you're
throwing lead weights yeah that's one of
my favorite things the Asgard ever said
is when he shows uh Thor has the food
and Sam's they're eating it because I
don't like it and he goes I like the red
ones
[Laughter]
yeah I like that so but I mean the
O'Neill because we actually did didn't
we see the Asgard Mothership and
anubis's Mothership actually could take
on Asgard vessels am I right in that
thinking um yeah
I think so I think yeah I think that was
the point where the Asgard realized that
they were no match and their dominance
and
their perceived dominance in the Galaxy
was then thwarted
throughout the entire history
although their numbers weren't that
great and they were kind of operating
under the pretense of we can defeat you
yeah we don't want to go old the go
award were just like
we won't mess with them not knowing that
they didn't have the ships available
because they were fighting another War
Etc I think at that point when anubis's
ship took it on
that was when they perceived dominance
kind of like tanked a lot and then you
see a lot of like gold after the fact
try and raise the raise to rise to power
which is why you see bar
um
like fill in that power vacuum I've done
Noob slip leaves
but you think the O'Neill would have
been
a match for her
the only match for anubis's Mothership
oh easily even with the ifrah the super
weapon
yeah I don't think I don't know
I want to say yes because the eight the
Asgard
were able to progress further in their
evolution if that makes sense whereas
the Ancients got to a certain point and
then ascended
so on our plane they didn't evolve
anymore well just as God couldn't Ascend
so they were continuously improving so
potentially
it would be a brawl it would be a
definite brawl like I think
if it knew this is Mothership and the
Ori vessels are probably the only ones
that could compete with the O'Neill ever
anything else would just get completely
smashed yeah yeah that's fair I think it
could definitely have destroyed both of
those ships they were they were by by
far the most powerful ships that we've
ever seen and we probably ever will see
because they would literally created by
ascended beings
or you know the knowledge was given by a
sentence guard upgrade to the dead list
the deadliest could take come on
one-on-one
once she's upgraded that's a shield
because initially they couldn't even
take a hit could they they couldn't they
couldn't take it here but the deadlifts
could take hits
yeah
but I think the maneuverability of the
all right ships made them much better in
a battle situation they were able to
kind of like
do do Maneuvers like a regular ship
couldn't do yeah
yeah and then they had the more powerful
weapons because they were taking down
Aura ships by the end and they were you
know fighting two three four at once and
yeah like you said there was zipping
them around and then taking uh as I said
like the Odyssey Shields could take a
hit I don't think they could take many
hits though could they because that's
the the one where they in the bubble
they're about to get hit by three and
they they know they're dead but yeah
with with all right ships I think it
took a few a few of us a few of our
ships to make a dent in an all right
ship but one or I ship could take on
three or four at a time which is why I
think they're the most powerful
yeah
yeah okay all right well we'll talk
about the ship I picked because um I I
picked um a classic really so I went
with the Prometheus the BC 303 or the
x303 when it was things 195 meters long
80 meters wide 65 meters tall could do
59 speed of light
um you know and it's sublight engines
the most weakly armed vessel it's
because like it had 24 railguns which is
not particularly useful weapon and 12
vertical launch uh missile systems which
a little Macado enriched type 12 nuclear
weapons but again pretty much useless
with Asgard Shields Asgard senses Asgard
transport technology it had ring
transports initially but left to the
refit HF the f302s are more capable of
fighting than the pig in than the the um
Prometheus but I love it because it was
the ship was designed perfectly for
where the show was at the time
um they needed to progress they needed
to create better ships but they didn't
just jump in at the end and that was one
of the reasons why I love Stargate so
much they made it like it was believable
it was used it was built using reverse
engineered gold technology it wasn't too
big it was not much bigger than you know
like an aircraft carrier sort of thing
at the time so you think yeah we could
actually build that and it was just
powerful enough that it could do stuff
but it wasn't so powerful that you know
it was silly
um what is that noise is it raining in
somewhere as somewhere as
there's a what does that mean I can hear
it but I don't know yeah I hear you
've changed
it's fine don't worry I just it was
getting quite nice
um but yeah the so the uh the reason why
I love the Prometheus so much is just
because
um it was a realistic Starship for
at that time of the show um she only
lasted three years launched in 2002 she
was destroyed in 2005. I just think
she's
she's a great ship she should have been
called the Enterprise as O'Neil wanted
but you know
we can't always have what we want but
yeah I just think it looked right
it it was the at the armor level and
things were right it's just it's just a
great Starship
would she have gone up against anubis's
Mothership
um and obviously we only got c1303
because the data less than three or four
was just so much more advanced that you
know and then obviously upgraded by the
Asgard again
um yeah I just thought she was a genius
vessel
right so finally
Harris could pick anything in Stargate
anything he had the choice of any
Starship any cool Starship he wanted to
go for and he could have literally done
anything
what did you go for Harris so I'll learn
a little bit of a different route here
as as I tend to like to do you know all
these ships are awesome they're all
badass and there's there's nothing you
can say about that you know they're all
great in their own ways and they're
vital to Stargate but the only ship
that's more vital to Stargate that
whether anything that we bring back this
is so useful that it should be in any
show movie or whatever because it makes
no sense for SG teams to not be using it
is the puddle jumper the puddle jumper
is
the perfect ship it's it's great it's
it's simple it it fits what four or five
peoples maybe six people up in that
front cabin and then you can fit eight
ten twelve in the back it's just enough
to get good infiltrated teams in there
and arguably I'm gonna I'm gonna say it
it might be able to beat any of your
ships because all it has to do is wait
while it's cloaked then go you know sit
on the ship and blow up the places it
needs to just like uh old Shepard has
done a couple times with darts and the
puddle jumpers themselves
there also is an experimental puddle
jumper that has a hyperdrive so why not
add that into technology after it's been
15 20 years by now and why wouldn't
every SG team be using these
and we would just be dominating the
Galaxy as humans
puddle jumpers for the win baby I don't
want to give you extra points but they
also have a Potter jumper that can time
travel yep yep yeah that's true that's
true because again that would be an
Ultimate Weapon and the Drone weapons
were incredibly powerful weapons so yeah
if you can get anything can deliver you
only need a couple of those drones and
you could take down much much bigger
enemies any of these ships all you do is
just cloak wait for their Shields to go
down while they're fighting somebody
else and then
and you're set sitting there on the
surface you look like a complete idiot
but when we scratch that surface
well you're still a complete idiot but
um
but no a beautiful idea I love it before
[__] Atlantis came out I was always
surprised we didn't have some sort of
[__] that can go through the gate yeah
there was that one ship in sg1 which was
a Jafar ship and we saw it on like one
episode and then we never saw it again
yeah yeah so we never saw it again we
said it was just impossible to fly
didn't they it was just really really
difficult to fly so they yeah but it
just makes sense doesn't it having a
ship that could go through the gate
because yet if if you're a server so tip
the Towery at that point Didn't probably
didn't have actually
yeah so when they're when they're
reverse engineering via the grow old uh
death glider they could have made it
round and then think well we don't have
hype Drive technology right now because
we're not that advanced what do we have
oh okay why didn't they why didn't they
think that's first
I think that was the probably the most
obvious thing they could have done it
just makes sense what you're saying
because the sg1 could only ever
basically explore
within a day's walk or something and if
they I mean I know they use drones and
they use things like this to explore a
bit further but yeah that's really what
it means that they used to send off and
stuff like the remote drones and whatnot
but just have a ship
we could have easily done it with the
with the reverse engineered stuff from
the death glider I was just so surprised
it never happened and I was very glad
when they had something in the stock
Atlantis
but also why didn't they ever leave any
to SGC
but they just they they have the gate
bridge and and at one point Shepard did
come through it's yes you see with a
puddle jumper why didn't you leave it
there
why didn't you say you can have this one
they only had like 12 didn't they so
they didn't have many didn't it I guess
they only had some yeah
yeah but Rodney had the two underwater
that he had to put together for to turn
into one to go help you know when
Michael was at the end of season or
middle of season five uh taking over the
base
it just wouldn't there wouldn't be
enough you know I I guess but now there
wouldn't be any reason for them not to
because it's 15 years
and then they can reverse engineer it
exactly yeah yeah
the Atlantis is on Earth though so I
mean yeah it is now yes but I mean maybe
we'll see puddle jumpers well damn I
have five episodes left and maybe the
new ones would be called gate ships oh
sorry I'll make the left
yeah let's call them gate ships I love
it
um Harris's genius strikes again let's
not let's
be careful
because he picked the best sci-fi show
ever made
and he said Futurama that ain't going
away anytime soon
all right um he's got he's got a he's
got a long a long way to come
I will lean into it forever and always
yeah anyway we've allowed an opinion and
some opinions are more wrongs than
others
um yeah
it was very very wrong
um but guys hey that's brilliant I I
tell you what if you if you're talking
about like shuttles and and spacecraft
from other series or even Fighters
really the puddle jumper is up there
because it's just
um
it's it's so functional in it ah we we
always read out our thing and thank you
so much for the contribution it really
helps really enjoying the show today
thank you sir just continue to write the
storyline do they need zpms I'm going
zpm
um to move forward to do SGU wrap up you
need them well let's go there's a
question for us in the new Stargate
series are we going to get to a point
where we're manufacturing our own zpms
not zpm it's 8 PM all right yeah but
it's going to be some janky Rodney McKay
version
and it's probably gonna blow up
hey it's a step in the right way in the
right direction right
yeah
it's going to take I don't reckon they
would have reverse engineered those in
10 years those things are Advanced as
hell
[Music]
which was like a it was a step in the
right direction with uh sucking vacuum
energy from alternate universes but then
they had Rod come in
um being like stop you're killing my
universe
please stop if you wouldn't mind awesome
stuff yeah I'm cooler than you and
everyone in my universe likes me
I like that storyline that we did you
know when we did um right we we did our
little thing we talked about what each
series of the new Stargate series should
be we were like
Amazon you can't figure this out we've
got it figured out for it and one of the
series we said was that basically the
um evil War e walks
of Steel Atlantis because they found a
zpm manufacturing base but actually
Atlantis sort of fits in with it like
two pieces of the jigsaw puzzle so they
were stealing the Atlantis to go to the
thing to build dead PMS
um even I'm getting irritated by saying
zpm
um I did it as a joke initially but now
it's gone too far
um and I I really like the idea I like
the idea of that that to manually they
have to manufacture them somewhere that
technology might still exist and maybe
that's what we find and but I like the
idea of that maybe the Ancients because
they knew how powerful they were broke
them up so it's like the city ships are
the missing piece sort of thing yeah um
there's multiple City ships because
there was that planet that had the tower
I think the episode was called the tower
um with a essentially a buried city ship
what if you need more than one
yeah maybe that's the point you need you
need a couple of them to work
so riddle me this I I do have a couple
episodes left so give me a wink if if
I'm if I'm screwing in in the wrong
direction and this shouldn't be a
an idea for for further things but they
could so
get zpm technology
just by going to the five or six
replicators that were thrown out in
space uh the doctor we're uh kind of
ones that came back at the kind of
middle of season five
if they're just still floating around in
space they're robots they're hanging out
yeah
they're very dangerous but if they were
also the ones that wanted to ascend and
they thought we were doing something
good for them we did trick them so they
would be angry at us
but if we could find a way to say hey
your friends teach us about zpms that
could be an Avenue or if we found a way
to get into their database or something
like that is something along those lines
I don't know
maybe I think the knowledge is probably
already in Atlanta somewhere it's just
it's so big it's going to take years and
years and years to even find it
well that's that's that's another thing
if it's been a decade 15 years since
we've seen Atlantis
how much more of it have they explored
and discovered and learned about I mean
I just watched the episode where they go
through uh is it Janice yeah Janice's
lab where they they fly through and find
the other asgarden stuff and I love that
episode that was really cool
it took five years for that you know
what happens in the next five 10 15.
there's a lot of City what have they
discovered we could come back in and
have a whole I mean human civilization
would look different especially if
atlantises on Earth which now I'm
ecstatic about learning about I gotta
finish this I've just understood that
evely walks is is now again in the
comments it's a it it's a bit of a
running joke that we have on the channel
um that the furlings obviously were
imagined by O'Neill and they look like
little Ewoks and I said that the the new
villain for the new series should be the
feelings because that's a species we
know a little about and we want to know
more about I just thought it would be a
cool twist for it to be
evil he wants so yeah
not really they're not really what but
yeah it's a bit of a running joke that
we've had but then I was just people
always said that evely walks
um I always think that now that that the
Atlantis is on Earth and that would be
being torn apart by Engineers they had
to build the zpm somewhere so yeah why
not on Atlantis somewhere that they've
just not found yet because I would think
it would be protected it would be hidden
at least at a minimum like a storage
room with like a you know obviously they
wouldn't be just out there floating
around but like you know
maybe 10 to 20 sealed cases when you pop
one open there's just a zpm sitting
cushioned in the middle
something like that I always thought it
would be in a place that's out of phase
so they have to fit the out of phase
technology
um where you'd essentially enter a
dimension of space that doesn't affect
the physical Dimension that we we occupy
at the moment so if you were going to
create something that is very volatile
as EPM you would you would create it in
a pocket of space that is not going to
affect your your current physical space
so you go out of phase you'd go in so so
essentially what they would do is they'd
go into a lab which would look empty
they'd flicker switch they would go out
of phase into that essentially a pocket
Dimension which was what the phase
technology used to do they manufacture
them and then they bring them into our
Dimension
because that one you could protect it
yeah because no one's going to steal no
one can break into the lab that's out of
phase but also if something went wrong
exactly yeah
our physical space
all right where's amberlynn
yeah that's some sci-fi riding thinking
cap I like that
yeah
you can have that one
[Laughter]
Mark Fergus you're welcome sir we're
helping once again that's what we're
here for today has anyone got Mark
focused his number not just no he's not
on Twitter or anything I don't think
I've tried to find him and I can't I
can't find him I think he's got enough
social media
um it doesn't look like the sort of
person that would get that excited about
social media anyway but guys thank you
so much another fun video I love the
Stargate live videos hopefully we'll be
doing it again in a couple of weeks
because we're getting more and more info
and I honestly think the fact that we're
seeing Amanda tap in and everybody
um from Stargate appearing in so many
Comic Cons at the moment is a very good
sign
um again everything I'm being told by
four or five different sources now
um but one in particular that like I say
good friend of the channel is saying
that this is still looking really good
it might get pushed back to left to the
right strike but you know what I was
gonna say would one final question would
anybody really care
in this you know and get into the
comments and tell me what you think as
well
if they don't do it at San Diego Comic
Con and they just release a press
statement saying yes it's true we're
developing Stargate and as soon as the
writer strike's done we're going to
really crack on with it
would anybody care if they just did that
that'd be fine I'd be fine I wouldn't
care per se but it it's it does take
similar I feel like that initial
announcement needs some humph behind it
you know and that doesn't have
announcement that we are 100 for sure
getting it on company letterhead would
still be a bit of a relief you know yeah
right right now we're still going on
inside information nothing's actually
official so
yeah
they announced it that way
it would be a little bit disappointing
because we wouldn't be able to see
hopefully what's going to happen with
Richard Anderson Amanda Tapping and
maybe Michael Shanks the crystal judge
on the stage announcing it and they're
getting everyone hyped up and
because that would be awesome
we're still going to get excited for it
and it will be channels like ours that
just spread the hype so yeah
either way but there was a preferred way
to do it I don't I don't really care if
they get an announcement or anything
else on stage I'm not going to be there
so
um all I want is for this to be like
really far along that next year when we
go to San Diego Comic-Con
hopefully
um if the channel still exists and you
never know we might just implode and all
just go I hate YouTube and run away from
it
um we won't you're okay
um but I want to be there when they're
like showing clips and stuff and they've
got the whole actors up on stage and you
know next year at San Diego Comic-Con
that'll be even better you know it's
like yeah okay great but
in a year's time
it might actually not be that far off
coming to the cinemas they could even do
a showing at San Diego Comic-Con they do
that some sometimes the sound of a
comment they actually show early
versions and things so
that could be us
in our side track t-shirts
don't give me hope
this is
I want to see all the Amazon Executives
going
sidetracks
yeah oh that'd be like the den of nerds
walking into a Star Wars convention or
Theory
yeah anyway you need to be like
[Laughter]
I was like I'm sorry stop throwing
things at me right guys thank you so so
much it's been an absolute joy as always
um
and yeah just really really brilliant
let's see what happens over the next
couple of weeks but
it's getting close I can feel it in my
bones but um thank you so much for
everyone attending and everyone in the
audience again we've had well over 100
people watching for most of the video
which is great we'll see you all next
week for whatever it is we talk about
and let's see what happens in the
meantime
I normally decide like Friday what we're
going to talk about in a stress oh God
it's Friday so
yeah so bye-bye everybody
see y'all puddle jumper for the win
have a good week uh puddle jumper for
the win
love you Harris
thanks everybody
foreign foreign
[Music]